franchement tu as pas laissé un trop
impressionnant ça va
c'est un voyage dans l'espace en fait
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire poétique et déjantée
d'un petit garçon à la comédie la saison
se termine sur la dernière création
d'Emmanuel de marsimota et de Fabrice
Melchio wanted Petula est un spectacle
où l'on retombe en enfance avec boulimie
Miro
et je vais du côté de l'étoile du
pare-brise
c'est un voyage dans l'espace en fait
c'est-à-dire que bouli va vouloir
s'écarter de sa famille pour aller
retrouver son amour depuis toujours qui
est sa cousine qui est un petit peu plus
vieille que lui qui est à savoir Petula
et donc il va vouloir faire ce voyage
qui va être en fait un voyage
initiatique quoi pour lui il va
découvrir l'espace et plusieurs
personnages le petit prince une puce
géante tout ça à la façon d'un compte
quoi